it's tough to take responsibility for
our patterns and for the things that
have gone wrong in our lives but it's
also the most empowering thing to do
ever because as long as it's everybody
else's fault that means we have no power
we're helpless like everybody else is in
charge they're running the show but when
we step back and we say oh actually i do
play a crucial role in my story
and i'm not responsible for the actions
or the behaviors of other people or how
they chose to show up or respond but i
am responsible for me and what i've said
yes to and what i've engaged in and how
i've shown up and how i've communicated
where i've sort of fallen off track then
we can start to do the work of taking
our power back
and it can be confronting because when
we go through those those passages
we might feel overwhelmed with guilt or
what if like what if i hadn't done this
differently oh i wish i hadn't known
this before why did it take me you know
until i was 40 or 50 or 70 to learn this
you know if only i had done xyz then i
would have you know had the relationship
kept my marriage not done that thing
but you know we're all just we're all
just walking the path in accordance to
our own timeline and we don't get to
control it and so i just say you know
it's never too late don't make yourself
feel bad
some people never get this opportunity
to wake up and so if you're in that now
it's a gift
you know and just really try to be
gentle with yourself
because i see a lot of people in that
where they're
they're waking up and they're having
these deep realizations that are going
to for sure make their life better
because they're aware
and yet they're so focused on the fact
that it took them so long to get there
or you know wishing they could you know
rewind and
do things differently and i mean
that's a trap
i feel like
when people
wake up
that they feel like oh man this is the
worst this is hard this is it's making
things difficult when will this be over
and i'm like you know they feel like
they're just starting i think is the
general feeling that i get from people
when they get there is that they feel
like they're just starting and i'm like
you have no idea how far you are you've
spent your whole life in a prison of
your mind of thinking it's everybody
else's fault and when you start waking
up to the reality that you are
everywhere you go right there and you
have your own patterns you're actually
so much further along in the process
than uh than you realize
yeah it's so true sometimes you know i i
do these group coaching calls every once
in a while for participants of my
becoming the one my program and i get
people who come on and they're they're
revealing these really honest and tender
parts of themselves and they're owning
the ways that they have sabotaged their
love lives or that they've fallen out of
alignment or the ways that they are
responsible for pushing people away
and they're just so honest
and it's breathtaking to witness and
then and then they go into this
self-doubt
i should have known this you know why
didn't i know this sooner and i'm just
like
i don't think you realize
how profound it is that you even are
willing to own
this about yourself
and that you see it because you're for
sure going to be a better person in
relationship next time like the way that
you show up is going to be
so much more loving and connected to
self because you're willing to own this
and that's all we can ask for right and
so i really do think we can get caught
in this trap of like never being enough
and never having
it right and not being perfectly healed
which is
never going to happen
we're never going to be perfect
it's as soon as you feel like you have
you know healed something then you're
going to enter into a relationship or
your relationship is going to evolve and
it's going to bring new things because
that's just the nature of life and
that's like the cycle of nature too it's
to
bring change
right with as the seasons change you get
new challenges you know in the summer
you're
you're faced with you know how do i keep
my plants from burning and how do i you
know keep everything watered and
nobody's overheating and then and then
you know right when you get that figured
out then you move into winter and all of
a sudden it's like how do i you know
prevent my
you know everything from freezing and
you know how do i keep the water flowing
and so
that's nature and and that's what we are
right so it's like we're expecting
things to one day just
fall into place and everything's easy
because we've done our work
and things do get easier for sure they
get way more pleasurable they feel way
more harmonious big things don't you
know small things don't feel like big
things anymore yeah um but there's still
going to be challenges along the way
and it's just we learn how to work with
them through working with our own minds
and our own nervous systems i'm curious
about the healed part you know there's
an idea that we need to come into a
relationship and we've like found
ourselves and we're a healed person and
um as you said so simply it will never
be perfect what about not being healed
from a relationship and going into
another relationship even if that
relationship isn't the self it's someone
else
is that a space that you can enter a new
relationship in uh or
should the focus be on working on
yourself until you've healed from that
relationship well look i think it's not
possible to
to fully heal from a past relationship
without
having new relationships and it doesn't
have to be romantic relationships but it
can even be friendships but
like we heal relationally
right because if we've had trust broken
or if we felt betrayed or if we've lost
hope how are we going to heal that on
our own like we need connection we need
other people so that we can remind
ourselves and reaffirm that love is safe
that connection is safe we can practice
communicating in a new way
we really do require relationship as
human beings to evolve and heal our
relational challenges so that's the you
know that's the difference if you want
to go and be a monk and meditate on top
of a mountain and not do relationship
then then sure but if you're going to do
relationship work you need to be in
relationship yeah and also the thing is
is like
most of us enter into relationships with
unhealed stuff from the past like i've
not yet met a person who doesn't have
something
that that isn't quite resolved or like
some
painful experience or memory that might
be lingering underneath the surface or
that might be causing some hesitancy to
let go or you know some time that they
felt betrayed or hurt and that's just
the nature of being human and taking
taking leaps and you know experimenting
in love
so
yeah i mean i would say
don't rush into a relationship when
you're feeling desperate
like if you've just gotten out of a
relationship and you're desperate not to
be alone and you're in this panic
because you need somebody yeah that's a
that's a red flag because the chances
are you're not going to attract somebody
who is super safe
right because you're going to be
attracting
just anyone you know you'll just say yes
to anyone you won't have the confidence
or the core to qualify but i i don't
recommend waiting until you've got it
all figured out to find a partner
because you'll be alone forever
thank god
what if we see someone outside of
ourselves a couple outside of ourselves
and we're really close to someone and we
can see that it's unhealthy how do we
address that yeah i mean it depends like
is it an abusive situation where your
friend is in trouble and you actually
need to support them in in getting safe
or are they just living out their human
patterns and figuring things out you can
be a sounding board and you can support
them and you can make reflections but
what i've learned along the way is that
even when i see that things are not
going to work or when i see a couple
that you know if they're obviously
not
bringing what what it takes to the table
to make it work there's something that
they have to learn in that relationship
before they're ready to let go and you
know i've seen this many times where
it's so obvious to me that this person
is not with the right partner
and
the relationship is clearly not good for
them and they even know it on some level
and yet they keep it going for a few
years and but then when they come out of
it it's like
that pattern really sunk in for them
they really saw it clearly and it's like
they needed to be
in that long enough to really see it
yeah and so
we have to let go and just let people
have their path because i know for
myself even
i've been in a relationship like that
where i've written about it in this book
where i
for years didn't even feel attracted to
this person but something kept me in
that relationship and that was because
it was such a karmic relationship for me
to see
all of my patterns clearly the way that
it erupted
and so as painful as it was i wouldn't
change it i wouldn't take it back
and we just have to remember you know
everybody's learning and all we can do
is love them yeah and that you have to
like it's back to the fire right it's
it's just that you hadn't felt enough
fire to really alchemize a pattern that
was unhealthy let's talk about
compatibility i'm very fascinated with
compatibility
my sister's laughing at me the other day
she's like you dated so many different
kinds of guys he's like whether they
look different act different like
they're so different and
i have a lot of curiosity around
compatibility and um
and uh and what what compatibility
really looks like in a relationship
and maybe also additionally from um an
attachment style perspective even
attachment style is funny because
if we're
more anxious we're definitely going to
attract someone who's more avoidant
you know it's just like anything about
that what do you mean
i know it's so funny i'm just like okay
you have to just surrender here like if
you are an anxious person
right now like if that's your pattern
you are most likely going to end up with
someone who is typically avoidant now
that's fine actually there's degrees of
attachment
you know
styles
right some people are really far on the
end of the spectrum where they're
completely avoiding they're just gonna
ghost you and not not show up but you
know everybody has some level of
ambivalence or avoidance or
whatever it may be you know and then you
know of course there's people who are
just secure
in pretty much every single couple and
person that i have ever seen or worked
with including my own relationship with
my husband there has been some level of
attachment to be repaired you know
there's some level of repair that's
needed
and so
i don't really resonate with this idea
that you need to go out and find
somebody who's secure
you see there's your attachment right
there
you're codependent sonny you're
definitely a codependent
love
yeah
how cute is that his name is sunny too
[Music]